hello i'm gav this video is sponsored by
google pixel today i'm going to be
demonstrating some of my favorite new
features of the google pixel 6 pro
in the past we've done slo-mo
multi-colored flames and we've done a
fire tornado so today i'm going to be
using this trusty bottle of flammable
liquid which will give us different
colored flames and
several fans and try and get a
multi-colored fire tornado it's a tall
order but i think we can do it now we
just have to wait for the sun to go down
okay the sun's gone down we've got
14 fans around this bucket filled with
various different flammable liquids of
different colors i'm just pouring in a
little bit of
the last color here
that should do it i'm going to film this
at a thousand frames a second in 4k
first i'm going to light the fire get
focus on it and then turn the fans on
oh
okay fans coming on
whoa
that is mental look at these plumes
probably like 15 feet up
look at that
all right
that is
okay that's crazy i was
i was kind of expecting all the colors
to be in the same place but you've got
red in the bottom moving into like a
yellowish green
and ending up in a very smooth looking
blue and look at that so the last time
we did this it was much harder to see
through it but here it's so translucent
you can see all the way through it you
can see the front of the vortex moving
from left to right and the rear of the
vortex moving back from right to left
it just looks so fake i think that's my
favorite part about it it just looks
like it's cg
[Music]
okay it's really getting dark now this
is gonna be just an absolute montage of
a video so i'm just going to try
different things and i'll just show it
to you
this one
has a very small bucket of
just plain old gasoline in the middle so
hopefully this will be a big bright
orange fire in the middle with all the
colors
swirling around it is that how fire
works i don't know we'll find out all
right the colored liquid isn't as fierce
as the gasoline so i'm just gonna light
that and
that should then light the gasoline
here we go
oh it's already going all right
fans coming on
this is actually a really good
demonstration of why i wanted to film
this at night you can see that the
regular old gasoline is so much brighter
than the fancy colorful chemicals that
you can barely see them in comparison
well it's not very colorful nice and
warm though
definitely take the old eyebrows off
so we're actually getting some color now
in the top
oh
it's a bit of a mixture
this is the same exposure i'm using for
the colored flames and you can see it's
actually blowing out the sensor it's so
much brighter so i think we're gonna
have to leave out the gasoline because
it's completely overpowering
a lot of the photos here i'm taking on
the google pixel are activating the
night sight mode which allows me to see
much more detail in dark areas we
demonstrated that in this video in fact
and i'll be using one of these photos to
demonstrate a new feature at the end i
think for the next shot i'm going to
have the camera looking straight down
so we can potentially see all of those
colors at once woo look at those streaks
interestingly because the light from
this tornado is made of all these
different colors the light that's
reflecting off these fans just looks
white
that is so cool
[Music]
oh
look at
[Music]
that looks like
pure evil it looks like a portal to hell
and all of the nice green is like the
souls leaking out that is crazy looks
like a black hole
[Music]
wow
oh just everything about this is just so
visually cool
the little tiny
specks in there it actually looks like
something you'd see in space
[Music]
i just like how it starts off as this
terrifying
boring flame and ends up as
these nice silky looking wisps at the
top
that almost looks good enough to touch
highly advise against it though
well that was some absolutely
mesmerizing looking footage i can't
believe that you could actually see the
progression from red to blue from the
bottom to the top of the tornado
definitely wasn't expecting that now i'm
going to talk to you about the google
pixel i've actually been using it
throughout the shoot to get various
pictures in addition there's now a very
handy under the screen fingerprint
scanner but the one that blew me away
the most was this magic eraser feature
in photos look how quickly this works
this is an unedited screen recording if
you've got something in the picture you
want to get rid of like these two
buckets here you just draw a little
bubble around them and then it cleverly
detects what you're trying to get rid of
you've got some full photo bombing your
nice picture bam i think i fixed this
picture in the google photos app faster
than it would have taken me just to open
it in a different photo editing app and
considering the time it took to do that
it's extremely convincing i feel like if
i saw this photo i'd have no idea that
anything was even removed and there we
have it thank you very much for watching
that video i hope you enjoyed it big old
thanks to google pixel for sponsoring it
make sure you check out the google pixel
6 on the google store subscribe if you
love slo-mo and i'll see you in the next
video